sans surprise devrait être Dimitri
Medvedev qui devrait devenir président
de la Russie puisqu'il a été désigné par
Vladimir Poutine lui-même un dauphin de
42 ans jusqu'ici peu connu son portrait
par Laurent Boussier et Volodia
polonsk logements sociaux université
hôpitaux usine s'il n'est encore que
vice-Premier ministre Dimitri Medved a
depuis plusieurs semain déjà un emploi
du temps de chef
d'État quand on rent dans s tout de
suite que notre pays est une
puissance né à Saint-Pétersbourg de
parents enseignants issu de la même
université que Vladimir Poutine ce
professeur de droit entré en politique
après la chute de l'URSS est un des
rares responsables russes à navoir
jamais travaillé au KGB patron du géant
gazier Gasprom Dimitri medv surtout
depuis 2 ans le monsieur social du
gouvern
vladimire signifie qu'aujourd'hui les
priorités ont changé il ne s'agit plus
de rétablir l'ordre ou l'autorité de
l'État mais de développement économique
et
social le plus important aujourd'hui
pour notre pays c'est la stabilité et la
tranquillité malgré un manque total de
charisme l'opinion publique façonné par
des médias sous contrôle lui trouve
évidemment toutes les qualités c'estme
JEE sympathi C il AR faire bouger les
choses l'oosition avec une code de
popularité passé en quelques semaines de
10 à 82 % d'opinion favorable sa
prochaine élection ne sera qu'une
formalité une situation qui lui permet
de refuser tout débat politique sa
manière de penser est proche à 99 % de
celle de Poutine et comme Poutine il
pense que l'argent peut tout il ne croit
ni aux valeurs humaines ni aux valeurs
démocratiques pour lui tout ça n'est
qu'une façade en Russie plus qu'ailleurs
il ne faut pas se fier aux apparences
derrière le visage lisse et les
seulement 42 ans de Dimitri Medvedev il
y a un homme parfaitement rompu à la
terrible concurrence voire à la violence
des lutte pour le pouvoir que se livre
les différents clans en place au kemelin